that newly authorized pill is called
paxlavid data from clinical trials shows
that it can reduce hospitalizations and
death by 89 percent for high-risk
unvaccinated patients if taken within
three days from when the symptoms begin
cbs news chief medical correspondent dr
john lapoop joins us to sort it out sort
it all out for us dr lapook it's good to
see you let's talk about that pill right
away
it says three days within symptoms do
you have to officially be diagnosed or
do you just have to think well i'm
feeling something because i know a lot
of us think we're feeling something
these days
yeah i think it's you know a combination
of the two and it's actually within
eventually five days because even when
you take it within five days of symptoms
you decreased the risk of
hospitalization
and death by 88 percent
this is a protease inhibitor and it
works differently than the vaccines you
know it's working on
the viruses ability to replicate and it
shouldn't really theoretically at least
be affected by all these mutations that
are going on at least not dramatically
so it's a very exciting development very
promising
how soon do you think it will be
available
well there was an announcement
by the government yesterday yesterday
that said that uh the first 65 000 uh
courses for 65 000 people would be
available about the beginning of january
so that's not very many and then
hopefully as the year goes by you know
it's
going to be rolled out in the tens of
millions it does take a long time many
months to make a pill and they started
this all many many months ago with the
idea well if it is successful let's make
sure that we have some in the pipeline
should vaccinated people take it too
well remember it's only if you have uh
covid so uh people shouldn't think okay
i've got pax lavid uh coming down the
pipeline and so i don't have to worry
about getting vaccinated if there's one
message that we know for sure that you
should get vaccinated and if you're
vaccinated you should get boosted when
you're eligible because that
dramatically decreases the risk of
hospitalization and death in fact the
cdc just announced that people who are
unvaccinated have 20 times the risk of
dying as people uh who have you know the
full vaccination
yeah i'll never understand why people
would want to wait for a pill when
there's something that can help you
right now i i don't understand
what's going on in people's minds but
i've heard people say well i'm just
going to wait for the pill i'm glad you
said please don't do that any idea how
much it will cost
well i think it's a little bit more than
500 but that's going to be paid by the
government uh the the the government has
said this is going to be free or covered
by insurance i guess uh for people so
it's not a an outlay that's not the
problem right now the problem is ramping
up enough supply i mean imagine 65 000
is not nearly to drop in the bucket when
you think about how many people hundreds
of thousands a day now are being uh are
being infected uh so it's it's it's
super important right now with the
holidays coming that people are very
careful especially in the week before
they get together with loved ones
because that's the time when you think
about if there's a
one to three or two to four day
incubation period for omicron that week
before people get together is really
crucial of course if they can get rapid
testing right before like the moment
before they're about to take off their
masks uh that's even better it's not
perfect but these are layers of
protection and the better the mask uh
the better the protection so i'm i'm
thinking these days of really the
highest quality n95 or or uh kf 94 or
n95 um kn95 uh you know whatever i think
the loosely fitted uh cloth masks or
surgical mess loosely fitted aren't as
protective yeah the the better the fit
is really important
yeah yeah
another point that we need to keep
making over and over and over again you
know we heard what appeared to be good
news yesterday john where they said that
the omicron variant is not as severe as
delta and others
do you think that that's true what did
you make of that because it sounded very
encouraging to hear
yeah there is some some evidence of
suggestions from south africa and
scotland now most recently that it could
be less severe but be very very careful
because remember in south africa for
example this was in a place that had a
lot of underlying immunity because it
had swept delta had swept through the or
some other variants had swept through
the country
so it's not clear
why there was an uncoupling of the big
spike in cases and
you wouldn't you didn't see as big a
spike at the same curve in
hospitalizations and even uh in
intensive care united states so that was
very encouraging and we saw something
similar in scotland but i wouldn't say
to people again if you're unvaccinated
and boosted uh if you i'm sorry if
you're unvaccinated uh
you know don't think that you're that's
gonna be a milder version of this virus
uh you know you shouldn't assume that at
all it could be really dangerous to do
that
now let me tell you something john you
don't want to get a mild version of this
virus either
really don't no you could have a long
haul you could have long haul syndrome
and you know we don't know what the
percentage of long-haul is with people
with omicron or even with people who are
vaccinated and boosted so don't don't
have one of these parties where you say
okay i'm going to get you i don't care
i'm giving up i'm not have i'm just
going to go ahead and get infected
because eventually i'm going to get
infected don't think that way try to do
everything you can to stay protected and
get vaccinated and boosted we can't say
that nobody in this room is thinking
that way we're all vaccinated
boosted up thank you john lapoop good to
see you